the activists The Advocates who are
willing to put their freedom on the line
they give me a lot of Hope young people
in particular give me a lot of Hope and
one young person especially
is giving me a lot of Hope
I I saw this kid's clip go viral because
a number of people tagged me in his clip
because I guess some people thought this
young man wearing smart looking chinos
and a nice button-down Oxford shirt has
his hair parted a little bit off on the
side
they thought maybe this young man and I
uh bear a passing resemblance this is a
12 year old boy from a Harrison School
District Two
in southeast Colorado Springs who was
kicked out of class for having a Gadsden
flag on his backpack in a Gadsden flag
that's the one with the snake and it
says don't tread on me this is one of
the very earliest American flags it
dates back to the American Revolution it
was a flag that was waived very high by
the Patriots During the Revolution and
the
Dei you know
counselor and enforcer of liberal
policies at this school
haranged this young man and his mother
for having the audacity to show a symbol
of the American Revolution the reason
that they do not want the flag we do not
want to play with me
is due to its Origins
slavery and slave trade that is what was
um just put a pause right there so you
see the mother says in the American
Revolution and the woman at the same
time she goes in slavery it's about now
of course the Gadsden flag
has nothing whatsoever to do with
slavery it's just com this isn't
something that is debatable or well you
have your opinion eye of my opinion
there's it just has no connection I
don't know how else to put it if you're
in any way literate about history of not
that long ago just a couple hundred
years you would know that but why does
this counselor lady think that the
Gadsden flag has something to do with
slavery well because she knows that the
mother is right
that the flag has to do with the
American Revolution and presumably she's
read
the only popular document that has
suggested that the American Revolution
was about slavery and that was Nicole
Hannah Jones's the New York Times 1619
project the thesis of which was the
American Revolution was fought to
protect slavery it's completely made up
even left-wing academic historians wrote
a letter saying this is complete
nonsense it's not true whatsoever the
New York Times did after the fact very
sutley have to retract that claim but it
doesn't matter they put millions and
millions of dollars into spreading this
total lie this fake news and it's made
it into schools it didn't just sit in
the newspaper the point of it was to
affect curricula and it has affected
curricula including the many many very
ignorant
I don't say that to disparage these
people I'm just pointing out they don't
know a lot of things a very ignorant
apparatchics who are working around
these schools who I don't know they read
it once in the New York Times and okay
so now that's the established fact so
you can see how an ignorant person could
be duped by that well the consequences
if those ignorant people are in
positions of power then they're going to
boot out a basic American symbol keep
going
obviously
the Galaxy one the don't tread on me
which is
the bad can't go back it's got patch on
it because we can't have that in and
around other kids so that's what I was
trying and then he said you were close
so I was like oh yeah it has nothing to
do with slavery that's like the
Revolutionary War patch that was
displayed when they were fighting the
British I am here to enforce the policy
that was provided by the district
and definitely you have every right to
not agree with it I mean
says that he's allowed to wear that if
you like go on their website
I love this it goes on and on for I
think two and a half three minutes
and that woman which she said this is
the most depressing part of the whole
video it's what this ignorant bureaucrat
at this school says this is yeah it's
about slavery the mother goes it's just
not she goes yeah okay well I obviously
don't have any arguments to back up my
points so
um look
I'm just following orders man
I'm just here to enforce the policy of
the district I don't know anything about
the the reasoning for the policy I don't
know anything about American history I
don't care about the Justice of the
policy or the truth of the claim that
it's based on
I'm just kicking your kid out of class
anyway
I don't care I don't care right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 as central banks and
countries like China China India and
Australia begin transitioning to a
digital currency the Federal Reserve has
been contemplating the same for the U.S
with a digital currency the government
could track every single purchase you
make officials could even prohibit you
from purchasing certain products and
easily freeze or Seize Your Money these
are some of the reasons that concerned
Americans reach out to Birch gold they
want to have a physical asset like gold
that is independent of the US dollar you
can protect your IRA or 401K by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty which is
right now learn if gold is right for you
too text Knowles kwles to 98 9898 and
they will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A plus rating with a Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
upon text Knowles Canada wies to 98 98
98 one of the oldest Flags
in American history it's it's not even
my favorite flag the the Gadsden flag is
in many ways more Anodyne than the
earlier American flags the Gadsden flag
is today often associated with the
Libertarians
or the tea party it's often associated
with people who basically just are
focused on economic issues or who just
want to be left alone
it's it's not the flag waved by hardcore
social conservatives usually it's not
the flag waved by the populists today
usually then you can see how maybe it
would be slightly more controversial
it's not it's Wave by nice ordinary
Libertarians it's it's waived by
sophomores in college who read iron Rand
for the first time it's waived by people
who have passing interest in 18th
century American history it's so basic
it's so anodyne
there are there are much more hardcore
early American flags the very first
American flag the oldest known flag
is a flag called the Bedford flag and
the Bedford flag is a is an arm covered
in a knight's coat of arms holding a
sword and it says Vinci out Mariah win
conquer or die
that's a little bit more hardcore
and
I think actually those two flags
represent a shift in the way the right
is thinking about politics for many
years for probably the last 30 years
especially over the last 15. the
American right has been the Gadsden flag
right don't tread on me leave me alone
do whatever you want to do just don't
make me pay for it and go do your own
thing and I'm gonna do my own thing that
hasn't worked because bureaucrats like
that lady in that school are always
going to come and try to stop you from
doing what you want to do and worse yet
stop you from exercising your rights and
worse yet stop you from speaking the
truth that's always going to happen we
live in a society no man is an island
entire unto himself so I think you're
going to see a shift from that early
American flag the Gadsden flag
toward an even earlier one vinche out
Mariah we are going to win these
cultural battles we're gonna Duke them
out we're gonna win these cultural
battles or our view is just going to die
out and our Traditions are going to die
out and our way of life is going to die
out but we are not all going to just
Kumbaya agree to disagree and go along
to get along we are going to have to
enshrine certain things is true and
certain things is false either true
American history is going to be taught
in schools or the 1619 project BS is
going to be taught in schools either
that lady is going to be enforcing a
false view of American history and bad
education policies or we're going to
boot her out of that school and we're
going to get a good educator in there to
enforce good policies with true facts
this is this is what Ron DeSantis saw in
Florida
this is why DeSantis Focus so much on
education we all have to do it and now
just before just to put a bow on it
I know people have asked if this young
man and I have any relation
I would just like to say
that boy is not my son to the best of my
knowledge as
we hear in the Odyssey by Homer as we
hear in William Shakespeare it is a wise
child who knows his own father but
as far as I can tell that boy is not my
son I am proud of him anyway I'm very
proud that's a very sharply dressed
rightly ordered well-behaved courageous
young man good on him and good on the
mother what a great clip that was huh
now make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles Show
podcast we'll see you next time